[Música]
economía aquí en directo américa me
acompaña en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge buenas noches comenzamos hablando
de eeuu porque fue aprobado por el
congreso una ley de reducción de la
inflación de qué se trata bueno se trata
de un proyecto que tiene una inversión
que ronda los 430 mil millones de
dólares y específicamente busca rebajar
el déficit programas de seguridad
energética y también la lucha contra el
cambio climático en la próxima década
también en la acción individual más
grande que el congreso ha tomado para
combatir el cambio climático la ley
aprobada en el senado de eeuu enviada a
la cámara baja busca mitigar los efectos
del alza de los precios hablamos de la
inflación más alta en cuatro décadas
muchos de estos recursos estarán
destinados a reducir las emisiones de
carbono y cambiar a los consumidores a
energías verdes al tiempo que reduce los
costos de los medicamentos recetados
para personas de tercera edad y refuerza
la recaudación de impuestos a las
corporaciones escuchamos
nuestro proyecto de ley reduce la
inflación reduce los costos crea
millones de empleos en la industria
manufacturera y mejor nuestra seguridad
energética es el paquete climático más
audaz en la historia de eeuu el senado
aprobó el proyecto de ley más importante
para combatir la crisis climática bueno
mientras tanto en colombia jorge el
presidente gustavo petro ya presentó en
esa reforma tributaria esperada por los
colombianos había mucha expectativa se
busca recaudar al menos este año unos 25
billones de pesos colombianos 26
millones de pesos adicionales en 2023
eso es el 178 por ciento del producto
interno bruto o unos 6 mil millones de
dólares y lo hace principalmente
cobrando a las personas con mayores
ingresos a las empresas financieras y
del sector extractivo la propuesta no
modifica el iva pero si crea un impuesto
del 10 por ciento a la venta de bebidas
azucaradas y alimentos ultra procesados
este último punto santiago ha generado
crítica porque durante la campaña petro
dijo que cobraría solamente las familias
ricas pero varios de los productos
gravables en la iniciativa son de
consumo popular como por ejemplo la
mortadela el salchichón las obleas
gaseosas entre otros también se busca
cobrar un 10 por ciento a las acciones
mineras y petroleras cuando el precio
internacional de cada producto esté muy
alto y reducirían los beneficios de las
zonas francas pasamos ahora a cuba
porque como les contábamos en el
informativo con ese incendio en la
región de matanzas cuba solamente podrá
satisfacer el 60 por ciento de su
demanda eléctrica por él iniciando en
estos depósitos bueno y también a otros
factores la unión eléctrica de cuba
indicó que esta situación se debe a las
dificultades que atraviesa desde hace
meses el sistema energético de ese país
que se suma a la desconexión forzada de
la termoeléctrica antonio guiteras una
de las mayores de ese país cuba depende
de gran medida del petróleo extranjero
para producir energía las
termoeléctricas generan dos tercios de
la electricidad y su principal proveedor
que venezuela ha disminuido notablemente
los envíos en los últimos meses y
pasamos a méxico porque el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador anunció que
limitará la producción de cerveza en el
norte del país porque qué es lo que pasa
allí bueno de hecho dijo que no va a
permitir producir más cerveza en el
norte de méxico esto por sequía que
afronta esa región por lo que solo va a
impulsar su elaboración en el sureste
del país
un estudio de cerveceros de méxico
revela que ese país está ubicado en
primer lugar mundial como exportador de
la bebida alcohólica mientras que como
productor se ubica en el cuarto lugar a
nivel mundial según la investigación
méxico es el número uno desde el 2010
momento cuando rebasó a países bajo y
como productor en la nación está por
debajo de china eeuu y brasil es
industria aporta el 15 por ciento del
pib de méxico escuchamos que decía el
presidente lópez obrador quieren
y seguir produciendo
cerveza aumentando la producción todo el
apoyo
para el sur sudeste
hay ser grijalva y el usumacinta
ahí está el papaloapan
y pasamos ahora a hablar de ucrania
porque el primer barco carguero que
salió de un puerto ucraniano con
cereales ya logró llegar a su destino de
finalización de viaje así que se llama
'el se trata del carguero turco por
learned que salió del puerto ucraniano
de turno mors la semana pasada con unos
12.000 toneladas de maíz y llegó a
turquía según lo previsto tras ser
inspeccionado por este centro de
coordinación conjunta el acuerdo
negociado por turquía y la organización
de naciones unidas levantó este bloqueo
ruso de los puertos ucranianos y
estableció las condiciones para que
millones de toneladas de trigo y otros
cereales comenzarán a fluir desde los
silos del puerto el razón y en realidad
fue el primer barco que salió de ucrania
en virtud de este acuerdo éste salió del
puerto de odessa el primero de agosto
con 26 mil toneladas de maíz y se
esperaba que llegara a líbano este fin
de semana pero aún no llega a su destino
muchas gracias jorge por esta
actualización de las noticias del mundo
económico a continuación en directo
américa al debate
[Música]